I I could have ate a veggie burger but
now I'm gonna eat a rib eye steak in
front of you hey you weren't gonna order
the veggie burger just like you weren't
gonna get the McRib
[Music]
all right there is a an apparently
famous chef who has recently broken down
super sad lots of Tears as vegan
protesters [__] his [__] up oh dude I
heard about that what happened did
Gordon Ramsay actually start crying
this guy's name is actually Chef John
Mountain cool name he's broken down
after weeks of protesting from vegan
demonstrators a group of vegans
including uh some Notorious activist
named Tash Peterson have come after his
Perth restaurant named fire like fire
Festival after the chef banned vegans
after a disgruntled customer complained
about a plant-based meal so he had also
banned vegans from coming to his
restaurant completely banned vegan yeah
because he just was tired of dealing
with them yeah honestly don't blame them
vegans why do they have to be so
obnoxious because like it's part of it
veganism vegetarianism they've existed
with Asians Indians Buddhists for
centuries a long time and they don't act
this obnoxious it's never been annoying
till now and then the thing is even yoga
like yoga practitioners it's been there
for a long [__] time but give it to a
white lady and then it becomes obnoxious
as [__] yeah what's going on on here
these are these are the questions that
we have to ask Nick what's the answer I
think um certain whites are very
entitled and I feel like when you
compare the identity of certain yoga
people
and veganism as like holier than thou on
top of the entitlement I think you get
this it's a combination I think I think
it's a The Perfect Storm of all these
situations and you know
like what Bard always says you just
can't take yourself too seriously
because also too it's like if you want
to condemn other people for animal
cruelty and what they eat it's like I'm
sure if you go back deep enough to
veganism and how they consume their
vegan products you could find a lot of
hypocrisy of how they consume their food
oh yeah what you have to kill a lot of
bugs right you have to fend off the you
know wolves or whatever you know to keep
your crop going you know the turtles
frogs a lot of rodents get chopped up in
the uh you know that thing uh the
combine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
unless they're growing their own corn in
their backyard shut the [__] up yeah bro
yeah but even then they probably get a
corn as a bug on the pipe flick it
before they eat the corner just kill the
bug yeah you just killed a bug
and wasting all the protein in the bug
thank you jeez I don't know I just think
it's it's silly dude it's silly and also
too just don't protest outside of a
restaurant there's other things to
protest yeah you're not really changing
the world yeah yeah dude get a job how
about that the only time I protest
outside of a restaurant is when they
stop serving something I really like
bring it back bring it back I want the
McRibs
why do you take it away and then when
it's when it's like there I don't even
eat it
and then with the McRib is back I'm like
when I see the Billboards I'm like it's
back yeah we should go sometime and I
miss it yeah
I think these vegans should just go
support a really cool vegan restaurant
yeah go do that
go put it put in some positive energy
because you know you're not gonna stop
people from eating meat honestly if I
just noticed that everybody was going to
this one restaurant and business was
going crazy and the line was super long
I would be more inclined to try it than
someone guilty me about a different
place definitely like I feel like I've
been to some vegan restaurants where I'm
like this is pretty good really good am
I hungry immediately after yes food
tastes worse when someone's standing
over you going doesn't it taste like
real meat yeah you're like okay dude
these are beets I know these are beets
that support that I hate when vegan
people show me food and they're like
isn't it exactly the same yeah I think
that's where they [__] up is like
they're trying to make replication yeah
like meat meals and whatever instead of
like just making a good freaking
stir-fry vegetable yeah like you know
when you go to a Buddhist temple and
they have all that vegetarian stuff it's
like that shit's delicious
some of the meat substitute is pretty
good though yeah but when you eat the
meat stuff do you go I wish this was
just the same thing but with meat do you
ever feel that way I don't mind I just
don't want someone telling me that isn't
it close yeah like what's the point you
know what I will say about vegan food
though would they knock out the park
even better than the regular version is
like the desserts the vegan desserts oh
like the baked stuff
yeah it's it's very good that's true
it's very good vegan candy whatever it's
always stuff that if they're not trying
to pretend to be me yeah and that that
stuff's not bad yeah solid So This Guy's
Restaurant so far has been stormed by
vegan activists with protesters holding
up signs about animal cruelty while
diamonds are eating some processors uh
stood outside the establishment playing
pig squealing noises while yelling into
a megaphone
um the the mountain this guy over the
mountain Game of Thrones uh he was also
even captured on camera grabbing the
megaphone from one protester as a woman
fought for control before security
guards had to intervene so he's like
he's like basically on you know the edge
of the cliff you're trying to like stop
these people from harassing his
restaurant harassing fellow diners while
they're eating and stuff like that but
they basically just got to a point where
he broke down uh he he at one point was
so pissed off that he wanted to open a
new steakhouse just to piss off the
other vegan stuff dude the vegan
protester one of my buddies he lives in
the Eagle Rock and I guess these uh
these protesters probably like 20 of
them were outside in his neighborhood
and they were they're protesting a house
on the hill
and they were just out there playing the
loudest Sirens like the most annoying
yeah they're just being annoying yeah
and they're doing that in a neighborhood
you know and nobody was stopping them
they were doing that for like couple
days a lot of hours just outside making
like just the most ridiculous noises who
knows what other nail there could be
pregnant ladies trying to get arrested
it's just like another homes so many
people live there why were they
protesting I forgot what the situation
was but the guy that was living on the
house on the hill was like associated
with something with meat or something
just hanging dead animals yeah yeah yeah
and they were protests to go and it was
just like causes so much
it's just annoying for everybody that
protests have the best effect on like
nowadays like when I think of veganism I
would however much meat I gotta eat so
I'm not like those people I will do that
I'll do it dude I just don't like the
people now yeah it's like not even about
the food yeah it's just like the example
of the people that I've run into are so
like unlikable to me that I don't I just
don't want to be like that I've never
seen a protester going like man they're
cool
I want to get to know your cops at the
protest the guys that have a drum circle
I always think that's cool yeah yeah
we're gonna [__] drum the [__]
protest oh the interesting thing too is
for this dude because it's Australia
like my um my girl's Australian and
she's was like following that and she
said it's different how like out there
the general population has his back like
his business is tripled good for him
that's tight but out here it would be
just like so he just needs to install
like some soundproof windows but the
problem is his private life is getting
[__] up like because like they're
boxing him well his his wife like left
him
because it's getting too much to deal
with like she just don't want a part of
it you know ah that doesn't sound like a
ride or die wife that's yeah that's
definitely on her yeah but also oh like
like what when you're dealing with that
kind of like hate all the time and
people just blowing you up I bet you go
a little crazy right like you they're
attacking your business you're probably
not the right mind State you're probably
lashing out like these [__] people
all you can do is talk about how they
piss you off all the time I bet that's
[__] tough dude
damn dude I don't know what I would do
because I I'm like
I actually yeah I'm on the same page
with you like it's I probably had no
feelings about the policy but because
they're so annoying like the protesters
are so annoying you want to go against
that you don't you just don't want to
associate with like like you don't want
to be like oh that's this guy I'm
exactly like him yeah I could actually
be before something like I could be for
animal rights but if I hate the
protesters so bad I'll probably start
eating like killing cows in front of
them yeah they're just doing it wrong
yeah I'll just do it like in front of
because I'm just like I'll go against
what I'm actually believing just to
annoy you I think just not everybody
responds to guilt the same way yeah
you can't use that all the time no you
got to change it up I think what pisses
most people off though is the the
entitled like condescending way of These
Guys these protesters are doing it in a
way where it's like assuming that you're
already an evil dumb piece of [__] and
you need to learn what they learn right
it they're not even approaching it in a
way where
they're giving people the benefit of the
doubt right yeah hey let's learn this
thing together they're just coming at
you like you're an evil [__] animal
killing piece of [__]
they're trying to like beat you and
you're just eating a hamburger like what
are you doing leave me alone
I I could have ate a veggie burger but
now I'm gonna eat a rib eye steak in
front of you hey you weren't gonna order
the veggie burger just like you weren't
gonna get the McRib
you're a bunch of empty promises you're
an enemy to both sides
[Music]